CLOSED QUOTE, THE PRESIDENT.
>> Bret: THERE WILL BE MUCH
TO MULL OVER IN COMING DAYS
ABOUT THE ROBERT MUELLER
REPORT AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S FOUR-PAGE LETTER
ABOUT IT.
BUT IT'S CLEARLY A POLITICAL
WIN AND LEGAL WIN FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS TEAM.
THE MUELLER REPORT BY THE
NUMBERS, 19 LAWYERS, 40 FBI
AGENTS, INTELLIGENCE
ANALYSTS INTERVIEWED 500
WITNESSES, ISSUED MORE THAN
2800 SUBPOENAS, EXECUTED
NEARLY 500 SEARCH WARRANTS.
IN THE END 34 INDIVIDUALS
AND THREE COMPANIES WERE
INDICTED ON 199 CHARGES,
MORE THAN TWO DOZEN OF THEM
RUSSIANS IN AN INTERNET
FARM.
IN TOTAL, THE 675 DAY
INVESTIGATION COST MORE THAN
$25 MILLION.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
KIMBERLEY STRASSEL, A MEMBER
OF THE EDITORIAL BOARD AT
THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL."
CHARLES ELLAYNA, OPINION
WRITER FOR "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
AND VICTOR DAVID HANSON A
SENIOR FELLOW AT THE HOOVER
INSTITUTION AND AUTHOR OF
THE NEW BOOK "THE CASE FOR
TRUMP."
VICTOR, FIRST TO YOU, WRAP
UP THIS WEEKEND AND THE NEWS
ABOUT THE REPORT AS YOU SEE
IT.
>> WELL, I THINK WE HAVE TO
REALIZE THAT IF HILLARY
CLINTON HAD JUST WON THE
ELECTION AND SHE HAD NOT
HIRED A FOREIGN NATIONAL TO
COLLECT DIRT ON HER CAMPAIGN
OPPONENT, WE WOULDN'T BE
TALKING TODAY.
THE ENTIRE COLLUSION
NARRATIVE GREW OUT OF THE
DISAPPOINTMENT OF TRYING TO
EXPLAIN THE INEXPICK CABLE
WHY SHE LOST AND THEN THE
DOSSIER TRANS INSURANCE INTO
A WAY TO ABORT THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY.
SECOND THING I THINK THEY
THOUGHT COLLUSION WAS
SEPARATE FROM ALL THESE
PROCESS CLAIMS AND
OBSTRUCTION.
ONCE THE COLLUSION LEFT MOST
PEOPLE THOUGHT IT DIDN'T
EXIST.
ONCE IT FAILED HOW CAN YOU
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE FOR A CRIME
THAT DIDN'T EXIST?
IF DONALD TRUMP SAID
SOMETHING ABOUT THE FUTILITY
OR THE WASTE OF THE
COLLUSION NARRATIVE, IT
WOULD BE SEEM POST FACTO AS
WISE JURISPRUDENCE, TRYING
TO WARN PEOPLE NOT TO DO
SOMETHING STUPID.
IT'S NOT OBSTRUCTION TO DO
IT.
FINALLY EVERYTHING THAT
BEGINS BADLY ENDS BADLY,
BRET.
THE IDEA THAT ROD ROINGE
STEIN
ROEIN
ROSENSTEINHAD FILED ONE OF THE F
ROSENSTEINHAD FILED ONE OF THE S
ROSENSTEINHAD FILED ONE OF THE A
COURT WRITS THAT WAS
MISLEADING AND GIVEN THE
RATIONALE TO FIRE JAMES
COMEY AND BEEN IN THIS
TRAGIC CIRCUS BEFORE WAS
APPOINTED WAS GOING TO BE
DISINTERESTED IN A WAY THAT
JEFF SESSION WAS NOT AS THE
OVERSEER WAS CRAZY.
AND FINALLY WHEN THIS TEAM
WAS APPOINTED THE LEFT AND
THE NEVER TRUMP RIGHT SAID
THEY WENT GIDDY.
IT WAS THE ALL-STARS, THE
DREAM TEAM, THE UNTOUCHABLE,
THE HUNTER KILLER TEAM.
THE REASON THEY DID THAT IS
THAT ROBERT MUELLER DIDN'T
EXERCISE JUST BASIC CAUTION.
HE COULD HAVE JUST SAID
WHATEVER THE LAW, THE
PROTOCOL IS I WANT TO EQUAL
MIXTURE OF CONSERVATIVE AND
LIBERAL LAWYERS.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
NOBODY ON THIS TEAM HAS
GIVEN EITHER TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN OR TO THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
NONE OF YOU ON GOVERNMENT
DEVICES, IF YOU WERE WORKING
FOR THE GOVERNMENT HAVE SAID
ANYTHING PRO-TRUMP OR
ANTI-TRUMP AND THEN FINALLY,
HE COULD HAVE SAID JUST
DON'T -- I DON'T WANT
ANYBODY IN MY TEAM THAT'S
DONATED TO EITHER CAMPAIGN.
HAD HE DONE THAT, AT THE
VERY BEGINNING, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN DIFFERENT.
NOW HE HAS GOT A REPUTATION
OF A CAPTAIN AHAB OR
RESPECTER RIGHT OUT OF LESS
MISERABLES.
>> Bret: CHUCK, I REFERENCED
IT WITH BRIT EARLIER THE
FORMER CIA DIRECTOR JOHN
BRENNAN INTERESTING THINGS
JUST DAYS AGO TO SAY ABOUT
ALL OF THIS AND THEN TALKED
TODAY ON MSNBC.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> FRIDAY IS THE DAY THAT
THE GRAND JURY INDICTMENTS
COME DOWN.
I DON'T THINK ROBERT MUELLER
WILL WANT TO HAVE THAT
DRAMATIC FLAIR OF THE IDES
OF MARCH WHEN HE IS GOING TO
BE DELIVERING WHAT I THINK
IS GOING TO BE HIS
INDICTMENTS.
THE FINAL INDICTMENTS.
>> I DON'T KNOW IF I
RECEIVED THAT INFORMATION I
THINK I SUSPECTED THAT THERE
WAS MORE THAN THERE ACTUALLY
WAS.
AND I AM RELIEVED THAT IT'S
BEEN DETERMINED THAT THERE
WAS NOT A CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY WITH THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT OVER OUR
ELECTION.
I THINK THAT IS GOOD NEWS
FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> Bret: CHUCK, I SAID
EARLIER THE LEGAL THREAT IS
NOT DONE FOR THE PRESIDENT
WITH THE SOUTHERN DISTRICT
OF NEW YORK AND THE
INVESTIGATIONS ON CAPITOL
HILL.
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF
BATTLE OVER WHAT OBSTRUCTION
MEANS ON CAPITOL HILL.
BUT YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE CIA DIRECTOR WAS TALKING
ABOUT THE FIRST TIME AND I
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT HE IS
TALKING ABOUT THE SECOND
TIME.
HE DIDN'T REALLY KNOW WHAT
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
AND THAT'S TOO BAD.
I THINK THAT WAS PROBABLY A
MISTAKE ON HIS PART GIVEN
THE PRESTIGE OF THE FORMER
OFFICE THAT HE CARRIED.
I DO AGREE WITH HIM THAT IT
IS TO THE EXTENT WE HAVE NOW
SHOWN THERE WAS NO CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY, THAT OUGHT TO BE
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY CAN
AGREE ON IS A GOOD THING.
IT IS NOT A GOOD THING THAT
RUSSIA DID ATTEMPT TO
DISTORT, DISRUPT, HOWEVER
YOU WANT TO CALL IT,
INTERFERE WITH OUR ELECTION
THROUGH USING SOCIAL MEDIA
AND ACCENTIATING THE
DIVISIONS IN OUR COUNTRY.
AND I GUESS I HAVE TO
DISAGREE WITH WHAT VICTOR
DAVIS HANSON SAID WHICH IS I
DON'T THINK MUELLER HAS -- I
DON'T THINK MUELLER'S
REPUTATION HAS BEEN DAMAGED
HERE AND I DON'T THINK THE
FACT THAT HIS TEAM WAS,
PERHAPS, FILLED WITH A BUNCH
OF PEOPLE WHO WERE
SUPPOSEDLY DEMOCRATS IS IN
HINDSIGHT A BLACK MARK.
IF ANYTHING, THAT FORTIFIES
THE PRESIDENT'S POSITION
RIGHT NOW.
WHICH IS LIKE, YOU KNOW,
EVEN THIS GUY WHO IS
EXPECTER COULDN'T FIND
COLLUSION ON HIM.
THE DANGLING PIECE HERE IS
THE NO EXONERATION ON
OBSTRUCTION.
DEMOCRATS HAVE TO THINK
REALLY CAREFULLY ABOUT
PURSUING THAT THAT GETS INTO
RELITIGATING THE WHOLE COMEY
FIRING WHICH IS SUPPOSEDLY
THE SOURCE OF THE
OBSTRUCTION AND THAT LEADS
DOWN A VERY, VERY DEEP
RABBIT HOLE.
AND I THINK SPEAKER PELOSI
HAS SAID WE ARE NOT GOING TO
IMPEACH.
IF YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
IMPEACH, WHAT'S THE POINT OF
PURSUING THAT OBSTRUCTION.
THAT'S A TOUGH ONE FOR THEM.
>> Bret: KIMBERLY, WE FOUND
OUT TODAY THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL FOUND OUT THREE
WEEKS PRIOR TO THE REPORT
COMING OUT THAT MUELLER WAS
NOT GOING TO REACH A
CONCLUSION ON OBSTRUCTION.
THAT SURPRISED BOTH BARR AND
ROSENSTEIN.
WE HEARD ALAN DERSHOWITZ AND
OTHERS SAY THEY SHOULD HAVE
YES OR NO COME TO A
CONCLUSION INSTEAD OF
PUTTING THINGS IN THAT
REPORT.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
WE HAVE OTHER PANEL AFTER
THIS TO TALK ABOUT IT AS
WELL.
>> YEAH, LOOK, I DO THINK
THERE IS SOME INTERESTING
QUESTIONS ABOUT HOW MUELLER
HANDLED THIS.
ON THE ONE HAND YOU COULD
SAY THAT TOSSING IT TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL WAS AT
LEAST PUTTING THAT QUESTION
IN THE HANDS OF SOMEONE WITH
SOME POLITICAL
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE
KNOCKS AGAINST THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS THAT NOT
NECESSARILY POLITICALLY
ACCOUNTABLE.
NOBODY ELECTED HIM.
NOBODY CONFIRMED HIM.
YOU CAN WONDER IF IT WAS A
BIT OF A WIMPY THING TO TOSS
THAT OFF TO THE AG AND LEAVE
IT WITH HIM.
ON THE BROADER POINT I THINK
CHUCK MAKES A GOOD VALID
ONE, LEGALLY FROM AN BE A
DESTRUCTION PERSPECTIVE THE
PRESIDENT HAS A WIN HERE.
NO ONE IS GOING TO PURSUE
FROM A POSITION OF AUTHORITY
OBSTRUCTION CHARGES.
NOW, IF DEMOCRATS WANT TO
MAKE THE POLITICAL CASE FOR
WHY THAT'S WRONG, THEY ARE
WELCOME TO.
BUT, AGAIN, EVEN IN LIGHT OF
THIS NEWS THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED, ONE OF THE
COMPLAINTS, FOR INSTANCE,
WAS THAT BARR HAD RUSHED TO
JUDGMENT ON THE OBSTRUCTION
QUESTION.
WELL, THAT'S CLEARLY A FALSE
NARRATIVE BECAUSE HE HAS
BEEN IN POSSESSION OF THIS
INFORMATION FOR THREE WEEKS.
MOREOVER, WE FOUND OUT THAT
HE CONSULTED WITH CAREER
OFFICIALS AT THE OFFICE OF